Hilary Clinton has been buzzing as the  first female presidential hopeful but  the Internet is drooling over her hot  nephew meets Tyler Clinton the 22 year  old model who broke the Internet during  the Democratic National Convention  Thursday after his shirtless photos went  viral Tyler is the son of Bill Clinton's  half-brother Roger jr. et has exclusive  photos of Tyler from his recent shoot in  Los Angeles and he might be stealing the  spotlight from his aunt again he's  giving us edging sultry sex appeal in  the series of black and white photos we  chatted with the photographer behind all  those steamy modeling shots that are now  getting attention Edina Doria tells us  working with Tyler was amazing he was  incredibly professional very  well-mannered and a truly genuine person  she added he's a model worth keeping  your eyes on